[Music]
Rage Against the Machine any fans [ __ ]
you know yeah okay cool I only know one
of their songs on that's the matrix one
I know a few you know I think you know
songs in you you know a lot of song do
you know that it's like testify that's
not one of their popular ones but yeah
yeah not like a radio so recently Rage
Against the Machine has been the talk of
Twitter because they are saying that
white right if psy right-wing fans have
been mocked for boycotting Rage Against
the Machine after realizing the band's
political stance oh the rage against
machines always been a left-wing band
yeah with much of their lyrics targeting
corporate America cultural imperialism
and government oppression but a number
of white right-wing conservative fans
have only just realized their radical
undercurrent of their music so there's
tweets that are like I used to be a fan
until your political opinions came out
music is my sanctuary and the last thing
I want to hear is political bs1 I'm
listening to music so they're all that's
[ __ ] Rage Against the Machine what do
you think that'd be so Tom Morello goes
Scott what music of mine were you a fan
of that didn't contain political BS I
need to know so I can delete it from the
catalogue it almost sounds like the fans
I go to just kidding news and they're
like why are you guys making jokes
where's the real news I used to like
when you did real are you just serious
news so people been roasting them on
Twitter they've been like what machine
did you think they have been raging
against for decades the ice cream
machine ATM lawnmowers people were like
next we should check out my favorite
puppy calendar Animal Farm
mmm-hmm so there's things like that
which is funny though because like I
don't know what do you guys think so far
they're stupid for not understanding it
like getting mad I remember being like a
little kid and not you a man yeah I'm
like not knowing what all the issues are
necessarily about but knowing what the
band
was about it's like imagine you didn't
like immortal technique now because you
found out they didn't like the
government oh and for those of you who
are having trouble recalling Rage
Against the Machine song okay so some of
those who work forces same that burn
crosses killing in the name of um those
who died are justified by wearing the
badge they're the chosen White's so it's
you know this version I got it but we
were the Bears or the chosen White's
well is he the same one where a fan
comment was like hey like oh why all
these people that become famous touting
their political aspart experts and then
he comes back he was well you don't have
to go to Harvard and because I graduated
early I can get it yeah political
science thing to be to talk about human
rights but just so happens I actually
went to Harvard and graduate with a
political science degree
Tibor for that yes it's also 42 because
their music is political like heavily
political system I actually just didn't
think it was left-wing I thought it was
more anarchist the system or like if
you're raised you get the machine cuz
like all machines because the machine is
machine is like both of them together
because like even if you're left and
like the socialist stuff is more like
giving the power to the government more
so then the right is like giving power
to the corporation's more so it's like
it kind of and there's all neo cons and
neo lives and it's all just a big
[ __ ] circle I just thought they were
anarchists to be honest right but that's
what's funny though right so do you have
a band they are they're like yeah we do
political statements that's what we do
like all this stuff and then it's like
hey you don't talk about political [ __ ]
if that's wack to me like if it's Martha
Stewart being like you let me talk about
politics real quick it's that's a little
different yeah yeah
yeah exactly they're like if you got in
their music you clearly were like yeah I
[ __ ] the man that's weird so they
never heard the lyrics then I guess they
didn't put it together that is a stupid
II should I've ever I don't I don't want
to listen to music I don't really listen
to the lyrics meet you I listen to just
31 thing would ever stick out
I'm not I don't work like that one I
cannot remember lyrics to save my life
even if it's like my favorite song I try
learn me too - I listen just for the
whole feeling and how it makes me feel
so they could be talking about killing
little kids but if it's a happy song
I don't think of killing locate the fun
so you're just singing along like murder
all the children I hate chilled song
don't be sick beat then does it change
it for you like when you find out what
the lyrics are cos for these people they
were like really into the band and then
they're like way when I hear murder the
children I'm hearing ma duh duh Cho okay
use your syllables they're just sounds
there's all sounds and notes to MIT to
me they just chose those because they go
with the song exactly yeah so I don't
really like what but then on the ones
that like I like maybe I listen to
20,000 times and then find like a line
clicks I'm like oh [ __ ] that was deep
I mean and I really liked it as like a
rap fan yeah as a rap rap fan it all
depends if I know it's like a vibe a
rapper it's not lyrical that I'm not
trying to pay attention you know I'm
just kind of like okay this beat is dope
and like the way he watch it cool is
like one that I actually Jay Cole you
put on and you're like I'm gonna
actually listen to this show or like I
feel like these people aren't even their
fans though like cuz if it's like those
people who just they see this tweet and
then they they use leverage against them
to try to like make them feel bad or
whatever it is if you're real fan yo do
you know what they're about give me a
break all right like I wish people did
this [ __ ] to senators though I wish they
like you all used to be such a big
family then you start talking those
politics and she to pastor had notice
that you talk about this a lot but
nothing you've really happened so like
or if they go against what they
campaigned for like they got voted in
and then you're like hey I was a fan
when you said you were gonna lower taxes
and you raised eggs bro
so you go to charging late can we talk
about so that's a little bit like like
video games pertaining my life more than
Jesus like like what are you gonna weave
Jesus into everything here about yeah
like Jesus was a second my big last
night Wow oh hey Zeus was
who's good at it Jesus why would even be
good at it are you saying you're good at
it no I said Jesus wouldn't be good at
all but because he was celebrated for is
I don't know but imagine like how does
someone I'm not gonna say I feel like
yeah you do a lot a blasphemous step
right up
I think you're already in I just was
saying that Jesus Paul wouldn't even be
very good because he's not but that's a
very holy statement that's Steve just
said it's just a it's a it makes sense
cuz he is celebrate very he was with
Mary Magdalene Virgin Mary is don't like
wasn't the chick the same name is
homosexuality so Jesus
well well here's the thing right so they
say they say like you know there's no
records of what Jesus was doing from
when he was born so like when he's like
33 so he's a carpenter well he's a
carpenter he also sitting with Japan he
went to Rome to hurt some people think
he traveled then definitely did not go
to Japan so people think Jesus travelled
the East and like studied Buddhism for a
little bit and then brought the Buddhism
shot okay maybe you went to Japan oh you
sure found a sandals store yeah I mean I
think that's all there was back then
yeah Sammy will have saddle sores yeah
he grew a beard more like the one guy
with the Santa sores was like making
money oh yeah there was a beer bong back
there that's a really old company me say
be a bomb yeah beautiful
is it beautiful Bible Bible long
Skechers dude oh yeah Jesus look like he
would wear sketches if you lived in
modern day I think he's more of a Tevas
person Tevas yeah what is that
Steve us of the sandals that the velcro
and stuff but they're really comfortable
Oh like Birkenstock expensive
I want him wearing the Crocs with the
flames on it the flames on it cuz I have
I bought a bunch I bought like a guy
fieri girls like a guy fieri Sharon like
a wig and stay with it accent yeah be
it's the process I know but it's funny
when people say it right it's funny what
he gets mad at if you don't say does he
really yeah yeah Dee but seems like the
whitest guy in the world of me
am I crazy okay I was at this
guy fury no safety area but he doesn't
correct them and then if someone says it
crazy that yeah that's how you actually
- yeah he's Italian right no he's
Italian I don't know I'm assuming from
the Fieri
I may be green nobody's white I just
think it so it was a clean way people
talk somebody like with no accent when
they're like in the sentence like
sometimes TIFF doses where's she's like
you know she's talking about like yeah
and then we went and got still talk
tostadas just yeah I do that [ __ ] now -
I used to I used to laugh at it but now
I got KC fun right it's it's necessary
it's necessary and also it's funny how
do you say Pat see you at the Thai way I
just pass to you it's necessary Tam you
say it the right way I feel like
necessary for the [ __ ] that like you
know where you need parts of you is ok
if you want sit with the Thai accents
Pat see you
that's it how do you say mango sticky
rice in the tire
Thai way in the with the Thai accent I
sticky rice is a townie oh ok and then
mango just made the county you kow Neil
yeah cameo brown cow why do they [ __ ]
you up like that so it's Pat hi Pat see
you right those are Thai words and
Austin the desert is not Thai it's mango
sticky rice its marketing baby it's
marketing they had to change it to
English words
yeah what about Pat I could they could
have called it like orange noodles and I
would have liked it that's true I don't
know where I don't know where those
names come from he's just funny when
people like a white guys like would you
like get some media or something yeah I
think they did I went to a Mexican
restaurant with George Kim wall which is
so bears he's actually he actually
speaks bad no but it's so [ __ ]
embarrassing because he looks whiter
than I do sometimes he's pink
yeah it's fries what's funny cuz I'm at
the Spanish restaurant they're like oh
do you want they say it's funny - I like
people used to correct me on my own last
name because it's the most narrow and I
always grew up saying llamosa narrow and
then he'll be like most NATO he must
metal and I'm like that's what I said
you said but what's narrow but it's the
most narrow and I was like it's my
[ __ ] name like I could say however I
want years
Crazy's [ __ ] Ariana Grande she was
going interview and she [ __ ] said
grandi hey she was like yeah blah blah
blah you know you know cuz you know when
my mom would call me like oh yeah you
know granny come here right now and then
like Ronde this whole time Andy so I've
been saying you assumed it was grande
that was gonna be it always not gonna
he's gonna garage what do you order when
you go to Starbucks a grande I got a
grande well I actually actually I get it
a banty I got tall at all I get American
medium [ __ ] yeah baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]